yo it's cam water I am here at the boys
and girls club in Memphis Tennessee
let's go check it out we have a great
facility it's always room for
improvement it's just minor work that
needs to be done for it we're getting
some help from our friends over at the
National Guard to make some improvements
in the gym let's get to work
they do look good they look great
y'all Sharon Jackson Jr I'm about to go
in there hang out and meet
the team what up gang
[Applause]
on behalf of the National Guard we want
to give you all these new basketballs
they look great this slogan right here
is for y'all because some of y'all got
some Elite Futures take everybody with
you
[Music]